how about actually building a
relationship my friends as we go more
Jetsons
the people that act like The Flintstones
are going to win if you're not deploying
services on top of your sales it's just
not smart you're leaving so much money
on the table and so like first I would
do that and then I would find ways to be
in touch with those people as often as
possible and then not just when you're
asking them for Goddamn money you're
super in touch when you want cash how
about when something big in their life
happened how about actually building a
relationship my friends as we go more
Jetsons the people that act like The
Flintstones are going to win your
grandparents are more theoretically
prepared for social media than you are
because they invented the baker's dozen
they invented when you walked into the
shop they started cutting your roast
beef because they knew who you were they
invented coming over your house and
giving you a cake when your grandmother
died now you have technology and you can
scale that can we please deploy some
soul and scale it
garyvee showed me